Researchers at Foundation Site 202 were going
about their day as they would normally, or
as normal as a day could be in the SCP Foundation.
If anything, normality was abnormal for them.
It was a quiet day at Site 202, as it had
been for a few weeks, to the distress of many
of the researchers stationed at the site.
No anomalies had breached containment in the
past twenty days, there were no random anomalous
events to investigate, testing was up to date
for all the anomalies they had contained in
the past few months, and their leads on potential
anomalies had run dry.
There was little to do at Site 202, and its
researchers grew restless as the piles and
piles of boring Foundation paperwork grew
ever taller.
That was until a fateful day in the Spring
of 1990.
It was March 22.
The cold winter weather had still lingered
in the air that day, but it was warming up
for all the people living around the Site.
There was word that a school, not too far
from Site 202, was experiencing an event that
could only be described as potentially catastrophic
to the SCP Foundation’s reality.
Of the researchers at Site 202, five were
deemed suitable to form a temporary task force.
The first, Doctor J. Alfred Henry a senior
researcher who was a former member of the
Mobile Task Force The Mole Rats during the
investigation into SCP-1730, the interdimensional
Site-13.
Doctor Henry also brought along his assistant,
researcher Tyler Zeissman.
The next member was Yavan Olich, who was in
charge of taking care of any living anomalies
that may be present at the location.
Another member of this team was Spriggand
Firestarter, a former member of the anomalous
Group of Interest: The Serpent’s Hand, which
specializes in magic and spell casting.
This project was overseen by Samantha Strysand,
the director of Site 202.
The team was not given a normal designation
as most tasks forces are: a greek letter and
a number.
Instead, they were called the “Taint Team”
and were in charge of documenting and combating
any and all parts of reality that were tainted
by the anomaly.
The team set out for the location of this
potential anomaly.
Along with their standard-issue firearms and
tactical armor, they were armed with portable
Scranton Reality Anchors and possibly the
most important part of their arsenal: their
expertise.
The location the taint team arrived at was
nothing they were expecting from what they
had heard about past reality-altering anomalies.
They were greeted with a single school building.
It was large in size; more a castle than a
school.
It was constructed out of red bricks, with
the roofs being slanted and white.
In the center of the building complex was
a large clock tower.
The researchers commented on how similar it
looked to a nearby church, and continued inside.
They moved throughout the school, looking
around for any sign of abnormalities.
There were three floors and two wings, but
all of them housed no anomaly.
The portable Scranton Reality Anchors each
member of the taint team held were not picking
up on any levels of reality instability.
They were close to calling the investigation
a false-positive and move back to Site 202
when a faint beeping noise was heard from
all the members of personnel.
Doctor Olich was the only one not to react
to the sound out of the team.
“It’s just a meat processing plant,”
he said sternly.
“There’s nothing in here except empty
rooms and dust.
Let’s head back.”
The rest of the team was confused.
“A meat processing plant?”
They were all briefed numerous times that
this was a school.
Olich was the first one to comment that he
recognized the location.
Was this the reality altering anomaly they
were looking for?
A school that makes people think it’s a
meat processing plant.
That wouldn’t be the weirdest anomaly the
Foundation has found.
One site has a yeti working for them.
But this, was rather underwhelming.
“What do you mean a meat processing plant?”
Inquired Doctor Henry.
“Whatever, let’s just go,” Olich responded
coldly.
Doctor Henry stopped him as he turned and
looked to his portable reality anchor.
There was a rise in Humes on the other side
of the main corridor on the first floor.
Humes are a unit of reality stability.
Baseline reality is located at a Hume level
of 0.
Anything or anyone with a Hume level greater
than that is able to affect reality in various
ways.
The team moved slowly to the other side of
this room, once again finding nothing except
the white drywall and tile flooring of the
building.
There was one odd element as they approached
this portion, though: a door.
It was not like any of the heavy steel doors
the team had seen in the building.
It was wooden, like the one you’d see on
a house.
The Hume reader skyrocketed.
It was a number they had never seen before.
4000 humes.
After a tense second of looking to each other
on what their next move should be, Doctor
Henry slowly reached his hand out to the door
and twisted the bronze handle as the rest
of the team drew their weapons.
He opened it quickly, finding nothing but
a dusty staircase.
The Hume reader plummeted back to normal levels
as quickly as it had spiked.
The team discussed what they should do next.
They decided to enter the basement level,
which they found was not listed on the floorplan
of the building.
Doctor Olich, insisted, however, that he remembered
this meat processing plant having a basement.
They moved into the dark stairway and slowly
progressed down the stairs.
It was an oddly short staircase that led to
an oddly small room.
The team was once again confused.
Why did the Hume levels hit a record high
if there was nothing but a small boiler and
a few pipes snaking on the walls?
Doctor Olich was notably absent from the team.
After some searching, he was found a bit up
the flight of stairs, frozen in place with
fear.
“Yavan,” Doctor Henry called.
“What’s wrong?”
There was no response, as Doctor Olich just
stood there frozen in shock.
Then suddenly the silent doctor began to walk
down the steps almost robotically; his eyes
were locked on the boiler, but it didn’t
look like anything was wrong with it to the
eyes of everyone else.
Doctor Olich entered the room with the rest
of the team and moved towards the boiler.
“You don’t see it?”
Olich said.
“The– the veins.”
“What are you talking about?”
Doctor Henry responded.
“There’s nothing wrong here.”
Researcher Zeissman moved toward Doctor Olich
in an attempt to calm him down.
As he approached, Doctor Olich became hostile
and began fighting the researcher.
The other members of the taint team attempted
to calm and restrain the doctor, but Olich
thwarted these attempts and moved to a corner.
“Blood!”
Olich cried.
“He wants blood.
A lot.
Blood.”
Doctor Henry began frantically radioing Director
Strysand in an attempt to get more help, but
as he did, Olich cried out the word Blood
another time.
A gun shot rang out.
His body fell to the ground, but his blood
did not.
The blood of Doctor Olich began flowing up
the walls in a jagged pattern, then began
to absorb into the concrete.
Suddenly, the Hume levels spiked in the room,
and the blaring alarms of the portable reality
anchors were all that could be heard.
The room switched in appearance, attached
to all four walls on the basement were hundreds
of long, thick veins.
They were red and black and purple, and dripped
a syrupy liquid of the same color onto the
ground.
There was almost a foot of the liquid in the
room, which the agents had been standing in
without even knowing it.
There was a mass slithering towards the corpse
of Doctor Olich.
It was black and a deep red in color.
It almost looked like a person, but it didn’t
move or act like one.
The entity absorbed the body of Doctor Olich
into its central mass and began moving towards
the remaining members of the taint team.
The Foundation personnel yelled into their
walkies that they needed to be evacuated immediately.
They sprinted up the stairs toward the roof
and out of the building.
Just as they reached the roof top: They heard
a terrifying gutteral rumbling voice mutter
the word “More.”
Their reality anchors’ Hume readers then
plummeted back to normal levels.
And a Foundation helicopter arrived to evacuate
them from the roof top.
The Foundation would designate this anomaly
as SCP-5633.
They devised a number of containment procedures
to combat the anomaly.
Site 202 was to be used as a drainage facility
for the anomaly’s secretions and all personnel
who enter the basement of SCP-5633 must not
have a phobia of blood.
As with most anomalies, the SCP Foundation
personnel of Site 202 decided to conduct some
testing under the belief that SCP-5633 could
speak to them again.
Blood, used for transfusions at the Foundation,
was transported from Site-17 for the taint
team to use as bate to attempt an interview.
It had been over a month since the taint team
had been to SCP-5633.
They remained with three members despite losing
one to the anomaly, as they were all familiar
enough with the building.
Doctor Henry placed down a bag of blood and
readied his reality anchor.
Immediately the blood was drained out of the
bag and began to flow up the walls of the
basement.
As Hume levels spiked, the room revealed its
true form.
The humanoid entity responded.
“I AM GLAD YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO.”
Another bag of blood was placed down.
“YOU ARE NOW PART OF MY CREATION.”
It was decided that two bags would be placed
next.
Doctor Henry believed that more blood would
potentially get a greater result.
“YOU SHOULD FOLLOW EVERY INSTRUCTION I GIVE
YOU.
YOU SHOULD GIVE ME BLOOD EACH TIME OR I WILL
STOP GIVING YOU INSTRUCTIONS.”
Another two bags of blood were placed down.
But this time no phrase was given from SCP-5633.
Instead a bundle of papers fell from one of
the veins.
It depicted the blueprints for Site 202.
Whether this was a threat or a message, it
did not matter to the personnel at Site 202
that was overseeing the project.
They commanded that all of the taint team
were to return to base at once.
While the SCP Foundation has ways to combat
reality-altering events, they also have methods
to look into alternate realities.
As SCP-5633 is one of these reality-bending
anomalies, it was decided a much more in-depth
investigation was needed.
It was found that in an alternate timeline,
SCP-5633 was a meat processing plant that
suffered a reality alteration.
The taint team, in that reality, had been
trapped in the meat processing plant only
to fight and destroy SCP-5633.
Somehow, they were able to disconnect SCP-5633’s
control on them and the meat processing plant,
then overseeing researchers were able to attach
SCP-5633 to various realities that were different
from its own.
It became confused and destroyed itself.
Did the SCP Foundation of another reality
accidentally send SCP-5633 to this reality?
It seems that way, so perhaps this version
of the SCP Foundation could contain it by
sending it to another reality, perhaps one
that it didn’t have power in at all.
The taint team decided that this was the course
of action they would take.
They reviewed the file they had recovered
from the servers of an alternate reality,
finding that blood was the correct sacrifice
to give to SCP-5633.
There was an issue though, the humanoid entity
within SCP-5633 had been growing larger, along
with its already intense power.
Tests were being run on the substance found
in the basement, as Site 202 had been draining
and pumping it into a disposal and storage
laboratory.
It was found to be a mixture of blood and
DNA from over 2000 different human sources.
There was a catastrophic accident with one
of the drainage pipes in Site 202.
One had been heated to intense temperatures,
causing a potential meltdown of the entire
site.
On-Site security and repair teams moved in
swiftly to combat the issue, however, the
superheating and rapid flooding led to the
pipe bursting from shock, splattering everyone
in it’s vicinity with SCP-5633’s fluid.
The fluid acted almost as acid, burning away
armor, clothes, skin, and muscle tissue and
embedding itself into the bodies of the victims.
They were immediately placed into temporary
containment, as, at the time, it was unknown
what would happen when the liquid entered
the bloodstream.
As always, tests were performed on the wounded.
They found that the entirety of the DNA of
those who had been victims of the liquid was
instead reading as SCP-5633’s DNA, not their
own.
For the time, the victims seemed fine.
That was until a week later when all the victims
of this event were found dead in their cells
with cuts on their wrists and throats.
Logically this would be the most efficient
way to drain the most amount of blood out
of their bodies in the shortest period of
time.
The oddest part of this entire ordeal: There
was no blood pooled on the ground whatsoever.
There were only faintly red trails of blood
up the walls of each cell.
That same day, SCP-5633 was observed to have
grown over twice in size.
If the anomaly could affect people who are
not even in the room, what’s preventing
it from spreading this liquid to all corners
of the Earth and drawing all of the human
races’ blood into its mass?
The taint team was given a supply of blood
to draw SCP-5633 out so that reality anchors
could be placed and it could be sent to another
reality.
The plan was simple, with Doctor Henry and
Researcher Zeissman placing the blood bags
down and communicating with the entity, Firestarter
would place down three portable Scranton Reality
Anchors to contain the entity for a time.
The taint team journeyed to SCP-5633, this
time accompanied by Director Strysand.
The site director believed that all the deaths
caused by SCP-5633 were at her hand, as she
had more than enough time to intervene but
didn’t.
This time, she was ready to send this anomaly
out of her reality by any means necessary.
The brick wall of the school had gone from
a nostalgic reminder of elementary school
to a nightmare of dead colleagues and the
potential death of reality.
They were careful when they entered, despite
knowing SCP-5633 was located in the basement.
Everyone on the team was tense but knew they
had a mission in mind.
They were ready to die in the dark if that
meant everyone could live in the light.
With a swift hand, Doctor Henry opened the
door to the basement, and the three other
members of the taint team followed suit.
The basement once again appeared to be normal.
The team knew this was a false sense of security
put in place by SCP-5633 so it could coil
around them and drain their blood so it could
grow in size and power.
The first bag of blood was placed down, and
the taint team was met with the voice of SCP-5633.
“I LIKE TO LIE.”
The taint team was perplexed as the bag began
to be drained of blood.
What did SCP-5633 lie about?
Another bag was placed on the ground and Firestarter
was commanded to wait.
“MY CREATION WAS ALWAYS INHERENT.
YOUR ASSISTANCE WAS NEVER NECESSARY.
I TOLD YOU IF YOU HELPED ME YOU WOULD BE SAVED.”
Doctor Henry, in a fit of confusion and rage,
threw the rest of the bags to the ground.
The only response he was given.
“I AM LYING TO YOU.”
Suddenly, the Hume levels in the room spiked
to 4000.
The room changed appearance again, now, the
taint team was almost drowning in SCP-5633’s
liquid.
They tried to scream but were only met with
mouthfuls of the disgusting black and red
mixture.
As fast as the liquid appeared, it was gone.
And so was the team.
There was nothing but silence and the soft
sound of slithering.
Personnel at Site 202 realized about one hour
later that something must have gone wrong
with this investigation, and hastily traveled
to SCP-5633.
Over 50 members of various Mobile Task Forces
and security teams entered the school and
its basement, only to be met with the disgustingly
cruel fate of the taint team.
SCP-5633 had reached a height of almost 20
feet.
Doctor Henry’s left arm and nose were seen
floating in the middle of this mass.
Half of Agent Firestarter’s face was seen
jutting out of what appeared to be the shoulder
of SCP-5633.
The legs of Researcher Zeissman were found
at the lower portion of the entity, laying
completely still other than random twitching.
The head of Director Strysand was peeking
out of the top of SCP-5633.
Her eyes had been completely replaced with
SCP-5633’s veins, and she appeared to be
crying the liquid constantly.
It seemed that SCP-5633 had been influencing
events from the beginning, from the death
of Doctor Olich to the pipe explosion to possibly
even creating the entire narrative of being
kicked out of another universe by an alternate
Foundation.
The SCP Foundation does know one thing for
sure though, SCP-5633 requires a great amount
of blood, and it just so happens, human beings
have a lot for it.
Now go check out “SCP-354 - The Red Pool”
and “Frightening Lost Ronald Reagan VHS
Tape You Must Watch - SCP-1981 & SCP-095”
for more blood-curdling SCPs from SCP Explained!